they're tracking down
a shape-shifting virus a mutated version
that evades the immune system
and to stop it spreading they're
pounding the streets
i'm admitting council um we're handing
out coker tests yeah
blanket testing a whole community in a
way it kind of is square one you know
testing again and you know a new variant
but um you know the quickest i think we
all went out the way as quick as
possible don't we
more than 100 000 people in a dozen or
so areas of the country are being surge
tested
in merton south london it's the south
african variant causing concern
but home-grown virus is mutating too
lockdown is a wind of opportunity to
snuff out the sparks of an outbreak
before people are free to move we've had
one case
several weeks ago we don't know what
would have happened to that case in that
time
and that's why we're working so hard
within
the neighborhoods within polar till
these guys going out
because we want to get on top of it the
garden of england the crucible of
coronavirus b117
the kent variant patient zero the
incubator of the virus has never been
found but the archive of virus samples
shows there was a case in kent on the
20th of september
another in london the next day but they
were only detected later
the outbreak only came to light several
weeks later in the midway towns of
chatham
and rochester during the november
lockdown cases were still
surging while they were falling
elsewhere in the country
scientists got curious did the tests and
only then
found they were dealing with a new more
transmissible variant
data analysis by sky news shows cases
likely to be caused by the highly
infectious variant
spread rapidly across kent during
december
into the eastern side of london then
country wide
its mutations giving it the edge over
the original virus
until the january lockdown slammed on
the brakes
in cambridge there are clues to how the
variants evolve
scientists treated a man with a covert
infection he couldn't shake off
after every new treatment the virus
completely changed
within seven days the the virus had
completely shifted its genetic
makeup billions and billions of
particles had shifted could this have
been how the kent outbreak started
first sequences are from september and
again that fits very nicely with um
with infection during the first wave in
april giving the virus a few months to
evolve and mutate and then spill out
into the
community once it had acquired enough
mutations to make it highly
transmissible
for geneticists it's a warning as more
people become immune through infection
or vaccination
the virus has to mutate to survive
lifting lockdown before
daily cases are in the low thousands
would be a risk says this expert
the virus doesn't care that we want to
meet our friends it's going to
try to find new ways to
transmit or to evade immunity and
to give you know public health including
the genome sequencing that we're doing
here
a chance to um work out
where the virus is mutating where new
variants are starting to spread
we really need that headroom of
getting cases down before we can
really uh take our fist off the break
back in merton
that worries louise she's been shielding
since march
her only company has been toffee they
can change the
vaccine slightly but how many more
variants are going to come in while
they're changing up
and if we don't stamp it out now it's
just going to spread like wildfire
and that's the urgency for the virus
hunters
thomas more sky news in merton south
london